diesels are highly popular in Ukraine
this fox wagon Passat has just arrived
from Germany
it meets Euro 5 emission standards some
mechanics take a close look at it they
know it'll need adapting to ukrainian
standards within a few months at the
latest that's when they'll have to
remove its catalytic converter problem
ah could the catalytic converters and
the particle filters often cause
problems they get clogged up very
quickly and stop working the diesel
quality is too low here without
emissions control systems the diesels
pump unfiltered toxic gasses and
particles straight into the air and
because regular inspections for cars are
not legally required in Ukraine exhaust
systems can be manipulated without fear
of detection experienced mechanics can
easily remove emissions control units
and replace them with a section of
straight pipe this one comes from a
Renault diesel if a converter is clogged
up the vehicle won't start we hook it up
with the diagnostic computer the problem
is very often a clogged up catalytic
converter sometimes we cut the converter
out sometimes we can repair it modern
instrumental wotty the ukrainian city of
lutes has a population of 240,000 the
air is foul and 82% of the pollution
comes from cars and trucks there's an
auto market here twice a month trading
mostly diesels private operators import
the cars mostly from Germany diesels
meeting older emission standards which
are registered in Poland Lithuania are
treated as transit vehicles for up to a
year only the later euro 5 standard cars
are actually allowed to be imported he
worries about the environment and that's
why the price of diesels is falling
Germany understands its people and
spends a lot of money on Environmental
Protection throughout the city a number
of stations are constantly measuring air
quality the results show that only two
other Ukrainian cities have filthier air
than
and now let's kiss filling up with
substandard German diesels the channel
the air will most certainly become
dirtier because these are the fuel
that's so bad for the environment equal
ye diesels have become hard to sell in
Germany and now they're flooding into
Eastern European markets the Germans
have simply outsourced their diesel
emissions problem